hey everybody and welcome to Oslo this
is a brand new and slightly unusual
series for me
partly because I've never done a
recreation series before but more so
because these videos aren't actually the
main focus of this project at least for
me they're more or less apply products
because I've been asked to recreate Oslo
and I figured I might as well record the
process and turn it into a video series
but it's not actually the main focus to
do so and why that is and what exactly
I'm doing I'll try my best to explain in
the rest of this video since it's just
going to be more or less standard fare
for me with time lapses with some
commentary over it
explaining the whole project and also
talking a bit about Oslo since as I've
come to learn it's actually a pretty
interesting city so there will be plenty
of time to explain everything so without
further ado let's get into the
time-lapse so in this first episode I'll
mostly be working on the map creation
itself there's some bits that are left
out of this and it's mostly the creation
of the overlay and the height map which
is something kind of tedious that I had
to do outside of the game by the way I
have to give a huge thanks to Krypton
city creators of terrain God's party and
the creators the overlay mod since these
were absolutely necessary elements to
recreate the map of Oslo but in the rest
of this episode I'm really just trying
to refine the map that came out of that
whole process and making sure that all
of these weird square bits and very
rough unsmooth parts of the map are kind
of smoothed out it won't be perfect and
I can definitely get into the details
later but I just want to make sure that
at this point the map is gonna be ready
to put the roads in place and get to the
city itself so all in all this is gonna
be a little bit of a boring process
which is perfect for me since this
episode I really want to focus on
explaining what this whole project is
and I know I've been really vague in the
intro but to be very honest there's not
much more than I can say
especially without going into territory
where I might say stuff that's not
entirely right since everything is still
a little bit vague for me especially
still since the whole project is still
in a planning phase but I'll try my best
to still explain this as clearly as I
can so a couple of weeks ago when I was
still in Japan I got this email from a
digital agency called hyper and they had
this project for me honestly they're not
really the focus of this the real focus
of this is the NMB you which is the real
star of the show here and the reason
that this is all happening it's a
university in Norway which is not too
far from Oslo and I think the English
name would be the Norwegian University
of Life Sciences which might not sound
too related but among other things they
educate city planners and architects and
urban designers that sort of corner so
you might already see where the
connection is here and their projects
which hyper tried to link me to is
basically that they want to have a
recreation of Oslo in city skylines to
use as a way to raise awareness and
interest in urban development and I
already thought this was a really cool
thing once I read that first email even
if everything was still really much in a
planning phase and still very ambiguous
since it's honestly always been
something which I thought City skylines
has a lot of potential when it comes to
because even though I don't really agree
with the some of the earlier sentiments
which came on especially in the TED talk
a while ago that City skylines has the
potential to be used by city developers
or city planners I think it has a lot of
potential to raise awareness and create
an interest in City Planning which is
especially relevant given that so many
people live in cities and so many more
people are gonna live in cities and yet
most people don't really understand how
they work and
can I can definitely see that city
skylines has raised a general public
interest in urban development so that's
really cool and that's why this really
resonated with me and what the
University the really wanted to do and
so the the project of the NMB you was to
pair up a streaming personality with
master students and have them look at
Oslo in city skylines to try and kind of
tackle but mostly try and explore ideas
of urban developments and issues that
Oslo is facing in real life in-game and
so it doesn't really have to be an exact
connection like there doesn't have to be
an exact one-to-one recreation of the
real-life issues since that's honestly
something that city skylines still very
much suffers from is that it doesn't
have perfect traffic simulation that
people don't act the same way that they
do in real life
and these kinds of things are just
really practical things that you can't
have in a game like this that you really
have to think about in real life let
alone things like property borders or
politics which are huge issues in things
like urban developments but not really a
part of city skylines and there are
things that you nonetheless can discuss
in the game and use the game as a
platform to bounce these kind of
dialogues from and so that's really the
idea of the projects to use these
streams to get this promotion for the
whole idea of urban development and
looking at the issues that Oslo is
facing which i think is a really
interesting way to use the game I think
we saw some earlier similar things I
remember in some other Nordic countries
I believe a while ago there was for
instance a project in Stockholm where a
new developed part of the city was being
opened in City skylines for citizens to
try and give their own input into how
they think it should be developed and I
think a very similar project was made in
another Finnish city as well so
I think this is kind of similar to how
city skylines has been used so far if
it's been used in a public sphere or a
commercial projects or any of that sort
of thing so yeah I think it's something
that the game actually does work for
quite well I don't quite think that the
game is a perfect tool to recreate
issues of urban development but I think
it's an amazing way to create some Civic
engagements in the field of urban
development and that is something which
I think any city can really benefit from
and so what the university was looking
for was as for the way that have been
put so far something that is a
believable copy of Oslo since obviously
there are a lot of problems if you're
trying to recreate a city exactly in the
game and so the focus will really just
be on making sure that it's a believable
copy that all of the roads are in the
same places that all of the terrain and
nature is more or less the same but
since there are really no assets
whatsoever from Oslo on the workshop
which is kind of sad I think a lot of
the other Scandinavian cities do have
some assets it will just be really
difficult to recreate Oslo exactly so on
a functional level it should be
recreated as close as possible with the
same road system the same infrastructure
getting the garbage to and from the same
places getting the water supply to and
from the same places etc and making sure
that when you look at it from above
you've got the same layouts and
everything looks the same but on a
street level it's gonna be very
difficult to recreate it and honestly
I'm not entirely sure yet at this point
how well it's gonna be done because at
the moment that I'm speaking I'm still
doing all of the road systems so we'll
see how that is gonna go but in the end
we should end up with a believable copy
of Oslo which can be used to bring up
some conversations about the issues that
Oslo is facing as a city at the moment
and yeah that is basically going to be
the goal of this project why I was
going to be the chosen person to do this
I'm still not entirely sure but we'll
get there at some points and I think it
should be fine in the end
just as a small update from my site by
the way if you're watching this and
you're into my city skylines contents
and you're wondering why I haven't done
anything with this game in half a year
at least on YouTube I have been playing
this game and I have been keeping up
with the workshop but I couldn't make
any videos of our city because our city
was on my computer back home and for
some reason I hadn't synchronized my
steam cloud before I went to Japan so
when I was in Japan I literally didn't
have access to our city so I know I've
been out of this game a lot on YouTube
but I've still been playing and I'm
still in this thing and I'm low key
thinking about another recreation which
I don't say much more about but as a
general life update yeah there's still
some more stuff for me to happen in City
skylines but for now this is just going
to be a side project for me and
something which I'm honestly crunching
on and which you'll see a lot more
videos of in a very short timeframe
since the deadline for this project is
actually coming up in about a week from
now at least from my side so between now
and the next two weeks should be when
most of my content is coming out on this
thing so it's all on quite a small
timeframe and really a bit of a marathon
considering that I'm usually sort of
spreading my videos out a little bit
more but yeah that should be fine in the
end I think it's about time that I also
talked about Oslo a little bit for the
uninitiated I suppose but also because
it is kind of relevant to talk about
certain parts of Oslo that are more
important than others so as a very very
general introduction for those who might
not be too familiar Oslo is the capital
of Norway and it's quite northern it's
really
one of the most it is the most northern
country in Western Europe and even
though Oslo is somewhere in the south of
Norway it is still quite northern on the
continents and it sits right in the
middle of a fjord
it's got lots of mountains around it and
most of water as well so it's a very
difficult terrain to work with and I
think that's also definitely something
that you can tell in the way that Oslo
has been made there are so many highway
tunnels and roads that go over and
underneath each other even in the centre
of the city it's really built on a lot
of different levels and that makes the
city very compact but also very
difficult to build infrastructure for so
it's really a little bit of a mess not
in a negative way but in that everything
is really one big spaghetti of roads and
infrastructure in the city so that's one
thing that's quite typical about the
city it's also a city which has been
growing very much only in recent years
and because of that it's never really
traditionally been a really huge city
like other European cities might have
been so the the city itself
architectural II is also a bit of a
mixture of a lot of old buildings a lot
of new buildings but an overall very
European style with very high density
and some of those real high-density
blocks in the city centre which is
nonetheless I still think a very typical
European thing and obviously it also
doesn't have that gridded layouts that
you'll see with American cities but a
very messy layout with roads kind of
going everywhere and no particular order
or scheme to the road layouts as it's
just an organic one that's just kind of
grown over the years in a way that I
suppose works best for the city and
especially in that very crammed
environment that it's in so it's it's
also presents some really big challenges
when it comes to recreating this city in
the game but that's also quite
interesting I think and there were some
really other interesting things
the city it's the only place where you
can take public transport to ski resorts
or at least like city public transport
obviously there are lots of buses and
ski or like trains going to ski resorts
all over the world but you can take a
metro with cross-country skis and start
skiing
apparently in Oslo so that's pretty cool
that's something which is pretty unique
I as a dutch person that's something
that i cannot relate to at all but it's
really cool to see that sort of thing
and it's also a city that is like
completely devoid of tall buildings it's
only got two buildings which i would
maybe call skyscrapers but even so
they're more or less just high-rises
just kind of drifting around 100 metres
tall and that aside there are pretty
much no tall buildings in the entire
city
even though there are some modern flat
buildings which are really high-rise ish
one of the most famous districts of the
city and the one that you might have
seen before on pictures if you don't
know that much about oslo but i've seen
it a few times is an area called bar
code which has been built very recently
it's also really controversial among the
people of oslo I've seen but I think
it's it's quite neat but it's basically
a modern developments alongside the bay
area the way that you see it in the
moment in many cities around the world
and it's called bar code because it
looks like a bar code it's kind of its
kind of cheesy but I guess it's an
interesting name to name it but that's
really one of the most well known sites
of Oslo and something that'll also be a
little bit of a hard thing to actually
tackle in this recreation since there
aren't any exact assets for bar code but
that goes for a lot of the city centre
same goes for the Central Station area
which is quite a sort of signature part
of the city which none of the exact
buildings are in the workshop for either
and for instance the City Hall which is
very recognizable building there's not
much for that either
and there is the oh god I'm gonna have
to pronounce some Norwegian words and
names from this point onward so I'm
sorry if this is gonna be very awkward
but there's also the the Akkad brick
area which is another sort of modern
developments alongside the water which
is also one of the main viewpoints that
you get a lot of pictures of when you
look up oslo i've actually asked some
people who might know more about this
how to pronounce it in norwegian words
but no matter how I try I just I just
can't replicate the sounds with my mouth
I think but in any case that's was
something I guess your you don't have to
do with I'm sorry about that but my my
scandinavian languages pronunciation in
any Scandinavian language is really
horrible
another thing that's quite interesting
about oslo is that it's a really
sustainable city it is one of the if not
the most sustainable city in Europe and
I think it's also going to be the green
capital of Europe in 2019 and it's just
overall a city which is very clean in
terms of energy use very lots of water
lots of open spaces lots of green spaces
and overall it's also very much focused
on densifying instead of sprawling
apparently they have closed down the
areas around Oslo from being like
constructed on and so it's kindly
similar to cities like Hong Kong maybe
in a sense that the nature around it all
of those Forest Hills are protected so
that the city has to look inside the
city for its expansion rather than
outside the city borders so instead of
the endless urban sprawl of suburban
areas just going on forever Oslo is kind
of limited by those hills around it
which is a challenge definitely and one
of the reasons why this project is
happening in the first place because
making sure to densify and expand a city
like that instead of just expanding in
city outward it's just a challenge but
at the same time it's something which is
quite good because it just makes a city
more livable more sustainable and it's
really just going to be something to see
how they can take these older districts
or the less dense districts of the city
and redevelop them
and that will also be one of the main
focuses of the streams which this map is
going to be used for in the end a
particular area which is going to be
important is an oh god I hope I don't
butcher this name too much but it's
going to be the area of a cone which is
written with the Oh with a rear diagonal
stripe through it which is a Dutchman I
really can't understand but in any case
that's going to be an area which is
gonna be a specific focus since they're
gonna redevelop it into an area called
hope Indian which is something like
Hoeven City or so and at the moment it's
basically an area which is very sprawled
out it has lots of parking lots lots of
roundabouts roads going everywhere
intersections industry and car retailers
and the idea is to redevelop it into
real city districts and add officers and
residential spaces into the area and
obviously turning such a such a space
into a completely different kind of
space is a huge challenge and that's one
of the ideas which is going to be
tackled in this map and which Oslo as
the city in real life is gonna have to
tackle in the near future as well so
that's an area which I'm also gonna have
to take into consideration when I'm
remaking Oslo since it's one of the
areas which I'm just gonna have to put
more detail in and some others speaking
of which by the way this is definitely
not going to be a detailing project
obviously it doesn't really have the
skill to do that kind of thing even if
Oslo doesn't seem like a huge city with
six hundred thousand something
population proper it's still quite large
when you consider the map of City
skylines since this thing almost exactly
fills the map of City skylines if the
map in this game were even slightly
smaller the the area that we wanted to
feature in the map wouldn't have been
large enough so just very barely cutting
it and I'm gonna have to come very close
to the edges of the map to finish this
as well so overall it's just on way too
large of a scale for me
- practically add a lot of detail into
this build but also for the computer
which this is gonna run on - practically
and a lot of detail because there's no
way that any computer would be glad with
a map of such size being completely
detailed so I'm obviously gonna have to
kind of be much more conservative about
the amount of props that I'm adding in
here but there are some parts where I
want to add slightly more detail than
others so for instance the city center
is just gonna try to be as OnPoint as
possible but some suburbs might just
have less detail and just be a general
Road layout and then just low density
houses being thrown throughout it just
by zoning and not really spending much
more time on that and the same goes for
some sites which are gonna be really
important like the bar code area I'm
gonna try to make them as realistic
looking as possible and the same goes
for the okarian area to try and make
that a good place to focus on in the
streams but at the same time other parts
won't quite be as detailed or get as
much attention besides there's also the
thing that I'm trying to do this in not
that much time from the beginning until
the end of creating this is gonna be
about two weeks of time and that is
starting from completely nothing so
there is also not that much time to make
this the best recreation ever focus is
really on making this a believable
recreation of Oslo and as for me
personally and maybe this is an
interesting thing to talk about while
this is going on in the background and I
haven't even mentioned it so far this
means that I'm taking the overlay of
Oslo and in this episode I'm just trying
to copy over the main roads which means
that in one window
I've got City skylines with the overlay
in the game map laid over the height map
so they are aligning and in another
window on the Internet
I've got Google Maps open to kind of
read what kind of roads and placing
where since obviously all that the
overlay shows is where the
are and I'm just comparing it to Google
Maps to see what kind of roads they are
so as much as I can I'm trying to put
two lane roads in places where there are
two lane roads in real life and
four-lane roads in places where there
are four-lane roads in real life etc I
tried to go to the level of getting the
same street lights unfortunately I
haven't really found any street lights
that are matching up exactly with what I
was looking for only in a few parts of
the city so it won't be quite that much
into detail but I think overall if
you're recreating a city in City
skylines and you're looking to do
something similar creating a height map
and then making sure you've got those
coordinates saved from the height map
you can take a program which I'll link
down in the description which is called
MMD entirely sure that stands for
anymore but the name of the program is
MMD you can take a part of Open Street
Map and take that exact part would you
give it the coordinates for and download
it as an image and so that's basically
what I've done I took the height map
imported it into the map editor and then
use the similar map to download an Open
Street Map image take that into whatever
image editor that you've got I actually
downloaded paint.net for this thing
because I only had Jim so far but it's a
little bit annoying so I got paint.net
to just quickly do this and invert it or
actually intensified the colors not
entirely sure of the English word for
this but in any case did that kind of
thing
got some plugins to remove certain
colors so that I would have an alpha and
a transparent map and then increased the
overall transparency of the map so that
you can actually see through it I would
actually highly recommend this so it can
actually see when I'm placing if I
didn't do that you would just see the
overlay right now and I think overall
that just creates a really good quote
unquote ghost overlay which you can lay
all of the roads underneath there are
some slightly better ways of doing this
I think there are some api's using which
you can exactly get a road system
without getting the names everywhere for
instance but I think this works fine
enough
it's got some of the advantages that it
does show some interesting things which
you want to leave in there so for
instance I left the green in there
semi-transparent to show where the Pikes
are or the orange / pink in there
semi-transparent to show where the
hospitals are so there are some major
things that I wanted to still show on
the map that I can still show them up
here so that's quite handy but aside
from that it's really just tracing over
the roads and making sure we get all the
main roads in place and by the way I can
already confirm that much the focus of
this episode is to get the main roads in
place so that would be the highways
around the city the tunnels that go
underneath the city and some of the
parts of the city as well as some of the
the main arteries when it comes to the
traffic inside the city itself and
creating the sort of rings around the
city centre and in the next episode were
you working on all of these small roads
which you can see in between here and
there won't be so much building yet
that's really one of the last things
that I want to get to just want to make
sure that the layout of the city is done
which kinda makes things a little bit
more boring I'm personally regretting
this at least a little bit because this
meant that I was just placing roads for
hours on end instead of just kind of
mixing it up and making it a little bit
more fun by placing buildings and trees
etc during the process but I think in
the end it's a little bit more time
efficient to do it this way and it gives
a better idea of how much time I'll be
spending on everything in general and if
it really becomes if it really comes to
that point where I'll be running out of
time toward the end at the very least
the exact layout of the city will be
here and all I'll have to do is just
make sure that I get the right themes
and zone all kinds of districts across
the city to make sure that all of the
right sort of buildings just fill up the
spaces between the roads where they
should say yeah that'll be quite handy
but yeah I apologize if it doesn't make
for the most interesting time lapse for
now I just think it's the most efficient
way to work but we'll get into some more
interesting things at some point it's
like creating some of these parks over
here
which I think will be definitely some of
the most fun parts of the recreation of
the city in any case at this point I
think it's fair to skip forward because
honestly I don't have much more to say
for this episode and the rest of the
time-lapse is gonna be a lot of road
placements so I kind of want to end it
here but not before I actually leave you
with some shots of what the final result
looks like at the end of this episode so
at the end here we've got the main road
network in place say for one road that
goes along the coastline all of the
islands and the surrounding hills of the
city have no developments on them or
nothing but just a few houses so that
will be something which I'll get to
later but it's not something of a main
issue to think about right now but all
of the the most important roads should
be in place right now and we should be
good to go to fill in all of the gaps
once we get to the next episode by the
way in this shot right here in the top
right corner is the area where the
future current is going to be which is
gonna be something which is quite
difficult and honestly which I didn't do
in this episode yet since it features a
lot of tunnels and roundabouts and both
of those things are kind of difficult to
do in city skylines but I'll get to that
at some point hopefully in episode 3
buying the planning of it but I'll
tackle that whole area as a whole since
it's gonna be quite important but
overall I am pretty happy with this
draft of the map so far obviously all of
the terraforming can still be slightly
adjusted to be a little bit more
realistic and like real life same goes
for a lot of these islands and a lot of
the foliage that'll definitely be
adjusted towards the series and the same
also goes for the loot I might make this
a little bit more bright and slightly
change up the theme but so far I think
it works out quite well and I think
we're off to a decent start so with that
said I would like to thank you guys for
watching and I hope to see you guys in
the next episode
you